I don't want to go don't want to go
spare please
[Music]
we spent it's no exaggeration years in a
room myself our executive producer at
marvel studios Trent ran joan anthony
russo and our screenwriters Chris Marcus
and Steve McFeely years in a room
working on infinity war and endgame and
one of the fun games was we had
character cards they were spread around
a table that were up on whiteboards and
deciding who was gonna go at the end and
who was gonna who was going to turn to
dust who would Fano who would be in that
50% pile and it they moved around a
little bit but for the most part it was
what you saw at the end of the movie is
is what we had determined early on in
large part because it would be the most
heartbreaking seeing T'Challa go right
after his first appearance seeing
spider-man go and Peter Parker after
that relationship had been established
between he and Tony Stark and it also
was designed to leave behind the
original Avengers because then game very
much follows their story he sees no
place today
[Music]
still equal
the end of infinity war was traumatizing
for us it was traumatizing as we made it
as we shot it as we cut it together as
the visual effects started coming in and
when we started to screen it it was it
was pretty amazing to see people sit
there and in shock that it had that it
had actually ended that way at the
premiere somebody told me a story that
they had brought somebody to the
premiere and at the end of the movie
they looked over and the person they
brought was crying and they said where
it a big premiere don't don't embarrass
me don't cry and suddenly that person
looked around and realized oh
everybody's crying and and that's a
testament to our writers to our
filmmakers who who put that together and
to our cast that has become so beloved
over the years that an audience is is
going to be feel that emotionally
drained by by their loss yes
[Music]
well I've been at Marvel now for 1800
almost 19 years and the notion of having
access to all of our characters was
always a dream it's soon going to become
nearly a reality and I started at Marvel
working on the x-men films and working
on early fantastic for films and that's
where I you know was very lucky to be
around some of those early films and Sam
Raimi spider-man films and we learned a
lot from from being a small part of all
those early movies that now and at some
point soon we'll have access to those
characters is exciting and it's just
it's exciting to have access to all the
comics because we love all the comics
there's so many great stories in the
comics and for many years we'd have to
put aside a set of those comics and go
oh we we don't have access to those and
now we do or will soon which is exciting
it's to get help I'm not doing get help
Disney Plus huge initiative for the
company and Marvel Studios has been
asked to supply content for it which for
us is another is another incredible way
to tell our stories we've told we've
we've haven't released we've released
twenty movies we've shot and nearly
finished 23 movies and that we finally
have a way to tell long-form narrative
stories and we're going to be able to
focus on characters who you've seen in
our other films but have never not been
the focus of the of a film the most the
one we've announced so far is Loki and
the opportunity to work with Tom
Hiddleston again and to showcase Loki
lived a long life
Loki's been around for over a thousand
years what what has he been doing and
really with these Disney Plus series
that we're gonna be announcing at some
point is is they will be 100% in to see
you tie them together characters you've
seen in the movies will go into these
series characters will change over the
course of these series new characters
could be introduced in these series and
then those changes or those new
characters will be reflected in upcoming
I'm not gonna fight your war I'm gonna
end it
one of the most exciting things about
Captain Marvel was making a film set in
a time period that we hadn't seen before
in the MCU seeing an early version Nick
Fury an early version of shield before
they had been exposed to these
intergalactic conflicts and bringing
Carol Danvers into the into the world
and understand where she came from
where she has been and as we head into
another movie we have later this summer
see her her grand return was very sad
day for us when we learned of Stan Lee's
passing a day that we on some level knew
was inevitable but thought perhaps would
be a long way ways and we were thinking
about how would we pay tribute to him
and honestly we've been paying tribute
to him for years into his work and the
work that he did with all of his
collaborators so the film's to us speak
for themselves and that the work is the
tribute we knew that on on Captain
Marvel the first film released after his
passing we wanted to start it off with
really a celebration which is what we
believe Stan would have wanted is not a
is not a mournful or sad thing at the
end of the film but a celebration right
up top and we've screened it now for
some people that opening of the movie
and it's really nice to see the to see
the rousing reaction to start off the
film